hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the world rabbit championship
sorry about so many uploads today but
for the next five days either turn off
the notifications or you you will be
receiving a lot of them as a lot of
games are being played and this is a
game from round to 11 RN and faces
Bassam Amin and although he has his nice
yellow yellow shirt here in the profile
photo in the tournament he is not
allowed to wear any bright colors as it
is regulations for the new dress code so
it's just no bright colors and like I
said in the previous video actually be a
problem for everyone but you know 11
always plays in his eye caught a
colorful shirts shirts called a colorful
shoes colorful trousers pants so now I
don't know it I'm very interested if
they will interview him and ask him what
what he thinks about that but okay
besides that the game is also quite
excellent so I'm sure we're gonna enjoy
it
11 with the white pieces opens with E 4
with E 5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6
Bishop to c4 detail in game is on the
board and now comes Knight to f6 so of
course as this is a rapid game 11
without you know thinking twice goes
Knight to g5 so the knight attack
against the two Knights defense we have
d5 the best replied there is to this
attack on the f7 pawn with a capture 75
and mountain Knights the a5 the oldest
continuation also an interesting thing
when I was you know studying opening
theory some a long long time ago in
books you always had nice to a five or
nine to d4 and this is you learn this
and you can play this but in the
tournament some year ago I actually
faced b5 over the board and I was like
what and I've never seen it and it took
me some time to to analyze it and I
think it was also a it was maybe a blitz
tournament or something like that and I
went Bishop to b3 which doesn't really
which isn't all that great because you
just allow black too much you can just
go nice to d4 and you allow black
do it too much play I want the game in
the end but still after this Bishop to
b5 if you ever see this just go back
there you don't want to capture it then
just Queen captures and well it's again
you're giving black too much if captures
would check capture Cu Castle black will
have a very you know normal development
Bishop d6 Bishop e7 you you can already
get some threats in so I just wanted to
mention this if you see b5 play Bishop
to f1 so now you know it and then after
whatever it's a black to capture so on
d5 you can just go Knight to c3 you
attack the Queen and then after the
Queen moves and now the point is nicely
attacked twice you can just pick it up
then with the bishop or if or or if not
you know you can pretty much play
anything but unbe five play Bishop to f1
I just wanted to share that with you
maybe all of you know this and it's only
me who saw it for the first time but but
still just in case so nice the a5
attacking the bishop
there should be five checks e6 so this
is all standard theory the captures be
captures and Bishop back to d3 again in
books you will in old older books you
will find Bishop to e2 as the main line
followed by h6 but Knight goes back then
you kick the night away with E for then
then you go go shove d6 and so on
Bishop to d3 however doesn't allow black
such things because of h6 you can also
go Bishop Knight to e4 as the bishop now
guards it so with Knight to d5 by Boston
I mean and now Knight back to f3
we have Bishop to d6 defending the the
d5 pawn and 11 castles with castles by I
mean and now rook to e1 putting more
pressure on the e5 pawn rook e8
defending and Knight to c3 now and of
course black is not interested in
capturing black ones White's the capture
so he can fix his pawn structure so f5
now introducing the thread of efore
which would adjust win material so that
shook back to f1 now now you will be
able to push her pawn get to the dark
square Bishop into the game and so on
with E for by black and Knight to d4 now
and Bishop to c5 so all the moves up
until this point have been played there
is one game where night back to f6 was
played but here Bishop the
c5 is plate and it is a new move so as
of move 14 we have a completely new game
night back to beat three now putting
pressure on the bishop here I mean
trades characters captures and the Queen
to b6 now putting pressure on the f2
pawn and Levin blocks with Luke - E - so
it's ugly it prevents the Queen and
Bishop from entering the game but black
Queen and Bishop will not be able to
remain here for very long because Knight
a 4 will just pick up a pick up the
bishop so Bishop to d4 and now Knight
captures on d5 you fix black's pawn
structure but in return you get d3 in
you you start to developing your pieces
also you cannot capture the rook would
hang and you are preparing Bishop to e3
to just finish your development with the
shop the b7 d captures on e4 d
characters and then only now Bishop to
e3 and I mean of course takes this
opportunity to pick up the the bishop as
if captures by the rook then f4 could be
could be very strong the rook who moved
in III follows may be playable but for a
rapid game you don't want to allow black
such active play so F captures on e3 and
now although you can push f4 here the e3
pawn is pinned Queen d4 is is just very
strong and now if characters captures
yes you do get these two strong pawns
but well white will get c4 in and once
d5 is played this Bishop is out of the
game so not not the greatest option for
to be played immediately but okay rook a
to d8 attacks the Queen Queen the e1 by
11 and now that a queen the d4 is no
longer possible f4 now we have Queen to
a5 offering a queen trade and now Amin
trades we have Queen captures rook
captures and f3 so he managed to really
push those pawns and now G captures an
f3 is playable but then you get it
captures and f3 attacks the rook rook f2
and rook captures on e3 so 11 did not
want to play this even though you can
capture on a7 now and you will be fine
we always have to remember it's it's a
rapid game you don't have infinite time
so rook F 2 he you know keeps keeps the
tension here there's
with the threat of rook captures I'm a
seven and now rook to d1 which looks
dangerous but it's really not since
there is no way to increase the pressure
although he does want to go rook e1 and
pick off the three pawn but okay eleven
captures on a7 attacking the bishop
bishop c6 and now h4 making some room
for the king we have also we just don't
want to allow this pawn to start
marching forward we have looked he one
now threatening to pick of the e3 pawn
and of course 11 does not allow it Rudi
to not eat sorry rook the rook to d2
sorry what rook to c7 first attacking
the bishop sorry about that
we have butchered back to a eight and
only now rook to d2 here you allow the
d3 pawn to be captured but for you know
in exchange you are getting the other
look to the seventh rank and then you
will have two pigs and then well the g7
and the h7 points will fall so if you
capture it right away then this of
course comes into play and if you don't
which I mean didn't he played rook the
f8 but it doesn't change anything all
that much here 11 just plays rook dita
b7 with f2 with check King to h2 and it
was actually in this position that
Bassam I mean resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here if
you if you capture the bishop then it's
just mate if if some of you are perhaps
beginners and and you don't know this
mate
King h8 captures here and now the other
rope delivers mate as the row kind of
fate prevents the king from escaping and
even if you don't capture it they really
aren't all that many moves you have to
move the rook
otherwise you're getting made it but
there aren't all that many good squares
still you're just gonna pick off all the
pawns in your fate you're gonna capture
here it's a Breton mate and if you
repeat then you just get made it this
way Bishop c4 check King f8 and rook a
to it mate so again with with the rhymes
on the channel the rook on h8 delivers
mate but yeah after King 2h - I mean
resigned and 11 shows again what a
creative player he is even though he's
not allowed to wear any colorful
colorful shirts and you know it's always
exciting when someone challenges
to the knight attack 11 shows that he
you know studies studies the theory of
the all the old games also but it's
bling being played a lot in modern chess
as well so not really not really that
big of a deal but people always enjoy it
I know I know I do so like I said that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it
we're gonna cover cover some more games
so you know don't be don't be you know
surprised if you receive more
notifications today you know and in the
next day and the next day I would like
to thank dog McNab Edward Baker Maxime
piece on inch in 1998 and torrents fight
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous video
serum thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the feed a rapid and bliss championship
for the next five days so thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day